black panthers and theaters now which
means we can have a full-on spoiler talk
let's do it I'm Dan Merle and I am
joined by Marquis and McCarty thank you
thank you for being here yes absolutely
we're gonna talk Black Panther so I'm
here any day every day especially for
Black Panther you have been I was
talking about this morning like we need
a Marvel expert you're like one of the
three people on our speed dial
like so when we're talking about who
we're gonna bring into the spoiler
review I'm like I need somebody who
knows their Marvel stuff and that's you
you know so much more about the lore of
this character then 98% of I think even
MCU fans I haven't had a chance to
review the movie Roth Cornett and Daniel
Radford reviewed it a couple weeks ago
and the embargo dropped but I was
curious you know just general thoughts
what did you think about it over okay
general thoughts and keeping in mind
that I'm a person that's coming from
Cannon with it I've grown up with Black
Panther kind of a thing and there are
different runs I go with it you know
everything from it starts with a Jack
Kirby and Stan Lee there's a MacGregor
run in there jungle action and then
Christopher priests run which is my
absolute favorite the one that I
recommend to everybody and then you know
it goes on Jason Aaron has a thing in
there with the secret evasion Reginald
Hudlin
and of course Tommy he siku coats and
Roxane gay I legitimately feel that Ryan
Coogler like cherry picks the best out
of all of these runs and then put them
into this beautiful it's Dan it is epic
it is epic
it is amazing epic in like a damn good
movie but it also it makes sense
I mean plot wise and everybody is a
fully realized character within it well
I agree with you it is a damn good movie
movie that I liked a lot it is easily
you know the first question that
everyone always asks is there where do
you rank it in the MCU it's like I don't
know I don't know where I rank most
movies in the MCU is like 1 through
whatever I but I will say it was it in
the top tier of the four or five best
that they've ever made and I think it is
because of what you said is there's a
kind of a base of what isn't a superhero
movie and I think that they live and
fall based on what more do you do with
that do you kind of do a kind of a Thor
dark world thing no which I didn't hate
that movie but it did you much other
than here's a guy who wants to destroy
something and you got to fight him yeah
and there wasn't much else to it or do
you use that and kind of build on it and
I thought that this movie did so much
building on top of that and adding layer
and depth and believability to its
characters which i think is what makes a
great movie and not just a great
superhero yes and I'd love that you
brought up layers because oh my god this
guy Ryan Coogler he's like he's a
parfait on top of a parfait on top of
another one because like the layers what
I mean yes you have like you said you
have this superhero movie but you also
have this social commentary you also
have this beautiful inclusion that
happens with this world where you have
like for instance Nakia is a wakandan
spy posing as a nigerian heiress in
Busan speaking Korean I mean you you
have this so you you also have like
South Korea's involved in there then you
have the dark underbelly that's gambling
in South Korea I mean and then not only
just that and you brought up a female
characters like women characters oh my
god how much did you love Sheree I loved
Sheree Sheree was great but for me my
favorite character not just female
character my favorite character in this
movie as far as like write a movie and
buy me a ticket was deny her I loved her
in this movie yes I thought she was so
amazing I thought you didn't you you
need you everything you need to know
about her character
you knew within the first two minutes of
screen time I thought that she brought
such a force and strength and what I
feel like has been kind of wasted with
her in the walking dead
particularly recently is she has such a
and just a steely just like I will kick
your ass and I feel like they haven't
really been taking advantage of that on
the walking dead as much as they could
have they haven't really given her
character that much other than just
she's tough yeah and this movie did that
and I loved her yes
the thing that I loved about this movie
with what they did with deny is that
they gave her humor or they let her have
humor I mean that one scene when it was
in Busan is the car chase and it's a
claw and they're shooting at the car and
it's her Nakia eye and she's just like
guns
on top of the car to throw a vibranium
spear yeah at this car but it's like
just her side I says so much
her smile be like don't freeze yeah
but going back to Cherie what you
mentioned another thing that I love is
like how great is it that you have a
young and it's like they're nailing it
with between Peter Parker and Cherie a
young kid who's just in the science and
technology and inventing things and like
it's good at it and I and I think that's
great to have a young character in a
movie who's not just kind of the
disaffected teen or not just there to be
put in danger but is like I got this and
his good at stuff that adults aren't
good at and can kind of set that example
yeah I mean she's absolutely fantastic
especially with that because that she
has so much a dimension to her like I
love that you brought up Peter Parker
with it and you when you see Tom haulin
is Peter Parker you feel like this is
actually Peter Parker not you know just
saying Peter Parker's past right but
sometimes you'd have in my opinion you'd
have an actor that would be a good Peter
Parker but not necessarily good
spider-man right and then someone who's
a great spider-man was kind of too cool
to be Peter Parker you know that kind of
thing with but yeah what Tom Holland
they hit that sweet spot with Letitia oh
right for Cherie they hit that sweet
spot of the depiction of her character
and then the actress herself because
like you have you have she's a stem
you know she's sciences technology
engineering mathematics she's
all that and she's funny and she's a
younger sibling that you can completely
relate to I mean when she was all what
it's like when a child is wearing dad
sandals I mean I could not even stop and
it is gonna be so difficult for me not
to use the term colonizer colonizer yeah
that was perfect
well this is a spoiler review but extra
spoiler alert because I want to go into
very in-depth about this so from here on
out suit your own super ultra hardcore
spoilers because what I want to go into
Michael B Jordan and and Eric and what
they do with his character and you know
there's always been talk of the villain
problem in the MCU what I loved about
Michael B Jordans character was it
wasn't just a generic it wasn't even
like they could have even gone just the
route of just like hey I I'm this guy
that should have ascended to the throne
and I want it and it's not even that
what I loved is that they gave him so
much depth and so much when they you
know his motivation and they did it on
both sides this is what I love about
movies that that that aren't afraid to
treat their audiences like they're smart
and they can understand thing which is
that the good guys aren't all good and
the bad guys have motivations that you
can understand it's like what Conda you
know you see two challahs struggling
with the idea of like what kind of has
been hiding these good things from the
world and they have done terrible things
in their past and and aren't they
complicit and some of these terrible
things that have happened because they
could have helped them they didn't and
then Eric who's you know it's
intentioned versus action his goal is
essentially just a complete takeover of
the world but it's motivated by the fact
that it's just like no I'm writing an
injustice I'm righting a wrong I've seen
what happens in society firsthand and I
want to write that but he goes so far
the other way that it's like I
understand why he's angry and why he
wants to do these things but his actions
aren't something that I can condone and
I love that it's not just simplified
it's very complex that's what I want
absolutely yes absolutely and the thing
of it is is that they even kept it Canon
with like Eric Gill monger well with
they had some you know finagling and
everything making him Eric Stephens
American black ops and and so on and so
forth but yes I'm like in the comics
T'Challa can't beat kill monger in fact
kill monk or became black panther
because he bet he beat T'Challa and
ritual combat which they even had sure
you know in this and you know you can
spend all the time in the world building
up a really great hero but like you were
saying if you don't have a black mirror
reflection of that hero in your villain
then what are you doing yeah you know
you just make cannon fodder for this
hero and we're gonna sit here and have
to get through that something with Eric
kill monger I mean and let's talk about
layers with that yeah for him to for him
to for instance do the ritual eyes of
scarification and then that comes from
Africa itself for him to he didn't know
Africa he was he was born in America you
know I'm raised in Oakland
kind of a thing for that character to
choose that particular scarification to
depict how many lives he had taken to
get to that point of him finally getting
the throne that that just that is
amazing um and what we said this is
super spoilery oh yeah this is all
spoilers okay I can't believe they
killed Eric kill monger I can't believe
it and then also he had such an epic
ending line mm-hmm that there was no
other way that they could have done that
character for him to bring up and this
is this is what I'm saying about how
it's so many layers with this movie for
him to bring up that he would have been
one of the ones that jumped over the
side of the slave ship mm-hmm that he
would choose death over bondage yeah I
both times that I've seen I've seen the
movie twice now i ugly cried because
that's something that you don't get in
mainstream that's that's one of those
really hard questions and hard truths to
like be butted up against and then you
have to ask yourself what would I have
done in you know don't know
have no and I'm so glad I don't have to
have to know yeah yeah
what and just the idea of the fact that
the movie really doesn't flinch when it
takes on I mean when you break it down
it is about the you know it's it's it's
we're used to with comic movies in
general somebody coming from the sky who
wants to take over the world and they're
gonna throw some lightning or whatever
it's somebody in there and then they get
defeated swirling portals portals and
liquids and whatever but you go from
that which even Marvel is guilty of to
and it's a trend because Michael Keaton
in spider-man homecoming is essentially
motivated by the kind of dissing
corporatization and and and economic
isolation of blue-collar workers which
is like wow okay that's a pretty current
issue and then they legitimately took
his job yeah they took his job and and
and the good guys took his just yeah
Tony Stark took his took his job yeah
and then and then didn't leave him any
other recourse well maybe there was
other recourse but you know black mirror
reflection of a hero exactly and then
now you have with Eric hill monger when
you break down I mean his plan is
essentially so an uprising some would
some would call it a genocide someone
it's it's certainly a motivation of this
kind of I'm gonna write a historical
wrong basically he kinda had the cure
for racism but that doesn't mean it's
good right yeah and that's what I mean
like intent versus action and that's
really the first times I've seen them
really tackle a hero was just like their
intention yeah right wrongs with
enforceable oppression yeah like with
the superior power and then you know
that's kind of the history of our world
yeah the people with the bigger better
weapons win and then they write history
saying hey we weren't that bad right and
then for the movie itself that line I'm
just like you're so blind you can't even
see that you're becoming what you're
fighting against
and I just it's so refreshing to see a
comic a comic-book movie like this but
but treat give them motivations it's
just like hey I see where you're coming
from and I certainly can't agree with
what you're doing but I can agree that
that guy's not right either and where's
this place in the middle yeah and then
you've got this kind of Game of Thrones
esque thing happening with the family
where it's like okay so two chil and
Eric kill monger all right cool oh wait
to Chaka murdered in Jobu who's the
father of Eric kill mugger
okay oh so yeah so their father killed
your uncle right he does have a claim
yeah oh it's it's just it's it's really
fun in that way that it's it's a hot
mess yeah like it's a family hot mess
yeah and I adore that and then of course
oh my god Angela Bassett yeah
Angela basses reminded the cast that
they have for Black Panther is
legitimately out of this world every
single person no I mean Forest Whitaker
Angela Bassett everyone we talked about
so far the circus is a maniacal treasure
he is I I'm curious to get your take
because there were there were a few
things that I thought you know I mean
that kind of not that I didn't didn't
like but there few things I was like
okay I think it's a little slow I
mitigate no movies perfect no movies
perfect not even Black Panther movies
perfect I love it but no movie is
exactly yeah I thought is a little slow
out of the gate and the third act I
thought you fell into some of those
conventions of like you have to have a
big fight between the good guy the bad
guy and the train and the Rhinos and the
Bigfoot it's like it's fun but it's like
okay but Andy Serkis was one that it's
just like it's both sides like I thought
he was great he was fantastic he was
great but I felt like that character it
felt like a bit of a remnant from age of
Ultron where it's like we set him up a
few years ago and it's like we kind of
have to pay him off in this movie but I
did sort of also feel like you know he
was there to kind of cackle and have fun
and then it's like okay he's out of the
way let's keep going
yeah I can definitely that's that's a
really good criticism for it because
yeah I mean when you when you think of
the two characters that traveled out of
that existed before and then came into
this I'm not including I oh I see their
IRA I'm not including her I'm Florence
Columbus character move or be moved
I'm not including her in that so with
Andy Serkis and Chadwick Boseman you
know they're they're coming off a Civil
War
well there are other movies and there
are a certain type of character there
that it kind of doesn't it kind of
doesn't jibe as well with what Black
Panther sets up and what I mean by that
is like you said with Andy Serkis I kind
of agree with you there it's just I
think he would have been different if he
had been Ryan's the entire time right
kind of a thing and like with them
Chadwicks character it for instance
during the throne scene when Eric kill
monger is like ask me who I am ask me
who I am ask me who I am kind of a thing
and Chadwick knows who he is but he's
playing it solo you know and it's very
very low Mike to the point where it kind
of takes you out of it well it took me
out of it a little bit because then I'm
like uh he's basically gonna tell
everybody in this room that your father
killed his father yeah that is about to
come out why are you being so chill do
you know that you're about to get
punched in the face like you're not
putting on it you know someone's about
to clock you in the jaw yeah so it's
like okay so there's that boob where
where was this you know touch Allah that
was going after Zemo and going after you
know Sebastian right now Sebastian sorry
let me call him by his bus tub yeah
Sebby said it's like where where was
that guy
well it's it just that the other thing
that I kind of wrote down was and it's
not I hadn't really thought chadwick
boseman I thought that his performance
was great when I felt also that in a
weird kind of way for me Black Panther
was kind of the least interesting
character in the movie I was so much
more invested in every
one around him and I thought they were
all and I think it's just you have to
introduce so many people that I think
part of when you're writing it part of
the convention has to be that you have
to bounce them off of your main
characters black panther to show their
character traits you know like what are
those like you have to kind of but you
have to let them sit right shine in that
scene to establish your character you
have to let Danai gurira shine to
establish her character you have to let
Eric Michael Jordan shine in the scene
to establish that character but I think
part of that is that in the process
you're sort of sidelining your main
character because you have to introduce
all of these other people and so I that
was part of me was like you know while I
thought Chadwick Boseman was great he
gave a great performance in a lot of
ways I thought he was kind of the
character that was there for everyone
else to bounce off of and motivate and
so I feel like you know this this could
have been a little more black panther
centric in the sense of just like he was
he's like the sixth or seventh thing
that I think about when I think about
what I love about this movie is great
the plan is great
Bozeman was good too yeah no I I totally
understand what you're saying and it's
it's an excellent point actually the the
way that I was thinking about it and
yeah yeah when I think of the things
that I loved about it my first one is
Sheree you know and then probably deny
and then probably just the general
afrofuturism of everything yeah and so
on and so forth with him I guess we are
I'm also I keep it in mind that this is
the first time that we've had a
character of this type this is a king
this is a king in a superhero world and
we haven't had that we've had a you know
single super soldier that you know
government uses him as a shill buy war
bonds right no kind of thing we've had a
you know man in a cave existing alone
with the butler and but we haven't had
someone who has all of the
responsibilities and perhaps with that
with T'Challa he has to be defined by
the country that he runs or for that his
his close counsel the people around him
I mean the way that they treat him says
a lot about his character because you
have these incredibly powerful people
that
him with this council with Ramon de with
what hobby
Daniel Kalu use character and so on like
these are these are some pretty powerful
people with powerful opinions and for
them to defer to him when eventually
they don't defer to Erick kill monger
that does say it's kind of something
unspoken but I totally get what you're
saying - I'm curious your take on you
know as we speak we're filming this the
day before the movie comes out but we'll
probably know this weekend how it how it
does I mean financially it's gonna be
everything that we're reading is gonna
be a huge opening I'm curious your take
on this you know because this is
obviously a big moment in the
superheroes just cuz it's gonna be one
of the biggest superhero movie openings
of all time but I think tied to that and
something that you you can't separate
really is that this is a huge cultural
moment in the sense that you know we've
talked today the four blade and we
talked about the fact that like there
have been black LED superhero movies
before blade and meteor man and know
these movies have come out but man
Blankman exactly exactly yeah but this
is you know you can't deny the first
time that it's kind of been not just a
black lead character but it is so deeply
rooted and not just African American
culture but also African culture and the
black experience has so much to say
about society seeing it kind of being so
mass-marketed it mass-marketed you know
where do you think that leads us telling
stories about not just black culture but
other cultures in the future do you
think this is gonna open up the
opportunities to people that say like
well you know it's a great story but it
would you know that's not it's not a
mass-market movie we could never sell
that kind of thing to an audience do you
think that'll help kind of break some of
those barriers down I think it's going
to do what iron man did where it's just
gonna like kind of explode the universe
out and and actually you can even
backtrack it even further than that I
think it's going to do what blade did
which that came out in 1998 and that was
a
decade before Ironman existed for like
the MCU right and basically what blade
did like I don't know if people remember
the 90s but superhero movies before then
were they were a campy joke I mean you
had bat nipples
you know spandex and Howard the Duck
which I love Howard the Duck but it was
Howard the Duck and it was supposed to
be a serious serie C sci-fi movie and
then blade comes along and it's gritty
and there's vampires and you know that
changed the game for superhero movies in
general so then you get Iron Man you
know beginning of phase one and that
changes the game and leads us into this
explosion of movies of like all of these
branches going off and you know now we
get to another decade after that you
know we're at the hopefully start of
another phase you know 2018 and then we
have this Black Panther which not only
actually okay here's another layer
mm-hmm it actually with black panther
the character himself like an comics
he's existed just kind of like filling
in the cracks and on he's been on
practically every team right just about
and like in and then Wakanda itself the
Wakanda design group a lot of the
weaponry that you see people assume that
it's Tony Stark's or that it's from
Stark Industries
but like quinjets that's what Conda you
know for instance like these ectoplasm
freezing bullet things that's Wakanda so
like with black culture that is filled
it feels like it's filled in the cracks
and done its own thing and has it's
helped steer the course it's it's it's
there it's alive it's like with this
with black panther that you can't help
but know that people are completely
interested and all of those other
stories so yes we want white tiger so we
we want her she's uh I believe the term
is a Latin X not dozer latina or Latinos
like Latin X and so yes I want to I want
to explore that and
and I wanna well we kind of have a
shattered star possibly and Deadpool too
but you know with like x4 so we can
explode that out and I believe and you
know I still want my Jubilee Mallrats
movie right and since and I think that
we can have that black panther is going
to do for marble and for television in
general what other movies have been
setting up for it to do it's going to
explode the universe yeah in the good
way exposed universe in a bad way
well that might happen and that's next
hey everybody dies that's what I call
that movie yeah you think that's gonna
be just the blanket just like we're
gonna everybody dies and then we're
gonna get a reality wipe with reality
gem yeah well we'll see what happens but
black panther I think you know both of
us I certainly a movie that I'd
recommend like I said just refreshing to
see a movie that's unafraid to just
really be real for lack of a better word
it's real it's grounded still with the
fantastical elements but it brings
actual emotion and and so many things
that you I miss in a lot of movies not
just superhero movies in a lot of movies
especially when you go into genre
filmmaking a lot of times they're like
well it's an unreal world so everything
has to be heightened and not real and I
think you can do both it's true
afrofuturism it's like it's the roots
and the branches at the same time and
even better with that um there's a place
for everybody in this movie and
everybody has in place Everett Ross it
would they have been able to do what
they did without Everett Ross would they
have been able to do it without a CO a
without Nakia
even without ramón de it's like without
Baku yeah
who is hilarious and Winston Duke is
amazing I claim him dibs dibs on Duke I
have no idea if he's dating anyone or if
he's into females but dibs let it be
known what this is the official
proclamation Markey is called dibs dibs
on whistle dude Markey McCarty thank you
so much for joining me to talk Black
Panther where can the people find you
anything that you want to plug oh yeah
well you can find me at murky McCarty
should say it at the bottom of the
screen I do Marvel movie news and that's
Tuesday is that popcorn talk and I do a
number of things with Nerdist so there
are a few videos about Black Panther
that are coming out today women of
Wakanda came out and there will be a few
more interviewed some of the cast of
Black Panther finding out different
things like the Black Panther challenge
which they raised funds not nervous but
Frederick Joseph from the Boys and Girls
Club of Harlem they raise funds to have
kids go see black pepper
oh that's all they did that over three
hundred thousand dollars raised wow
that's amazing
well mark here thank you for joining us
and you can actually right now go see
more kiyah on movie fights which we
haven't done yet but we will have done
by the time this is like a Marvel
timeline we're jumping all over the
place yeah I'm gonna walk out the door
right in today
exactly but you can go watch that right
now and you can watch us we're gonna be
taking on infinity war and all the other
big movies that are coming out this year
right here on screen junkies I'm Dan
Morell thanks so much for watching see
you next time
[Music]
you